je pousse le bouchon gérer les coûts de
florian mais tu me dis compris voilà tu
me dis et il m'a dit bon écoute
elle vient de sortir de chez bayrou et
donc tu lève le pied et après le monteur
non mais sur twitter on voyait parler
dans des conversations non parce que
nous avons des conversations privées non
on va aider des proches de florian
philippot et des assistants du front qui
dirait on va vivement qu'on ait une loi
d'exception une loi d'amnistié générale
s'étaient mis d'accord voilà c'est juste
parce qu'ici je suis bureau et j'ai pas
mangé des badauds dallas est ce que
j'avais dit l'on peut manger des
haricots
j'imagine que le sujet d'actualité
c'était cette fameuse ouverture d'
enquêtes et les suites à donner puisque
voilà prêt ça ça c'est une affaire
d'état
alors c'est juste une hauteur mars 2019
lorsqu'il a été lu par un certain nombre
de politiques personne n'a moufté
c'est encore une fois c'est des choses
alors bon c'est toujours il s'arrête
jamais quitté leur n a jamais su ça j'ai
quitté leur haine alors moi j'étais pas
un emploi fictif ou peut être un emploi
fictif en sens inverse c'est à dire je
me suis gt1 j'ai eu un engagement de
quatre années complètement bénévole à
auxerre ne vous étiez pas du tout pas du
tout payer our bon et quand on sent bien
que ça comme un gage dans un parti
politique c'est évidemment pour avoir
une investiture qui correspondent à la
fois votre engagement et à vos
compétences appelle un vus lequan et
n'ayant unis fans ayant eu une
reconnaissance ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre une raison de vous allez suivre
est resté non je pense que même un
honnêtement ma marine est une personne
que je respecte beaucoup
sauf que son entourage il y est dans le
nom son entourage et danses etc sans nom
et dont ce temps ses conseillers les
plus influents oui mais il ya des gens
qui ont une appli qui ont l'ampleur
intellectuelle d'un balais d'essuie
glace mais c'est facile c'est facile
c'est elle scelle la présidente du
mouvement
c'est elle la responsable si elle dit
niet part des dépenses et que ça peut
lui faire mal à marine le pen est ce que
ça peut lui coûter déduction ça non non
non non non ce que je fasse je pense
très sincèrement que voilà pour
l'instant ils sont haut dans les
sondages je moi je suis moins persuadé
que ça se concrétise je voulais je les
régionales est juste ou revenir sur ces
assurances sur cette histoire d'abord le
l'enquète du jdd là il n'y a rien de
nouveau sous le soleil
parce que le rapport qui est dont il est
fait état dans dans une
d'abord c'est un rapport de synthèse
parce qu'il ya un changement de juge et
il ya effectivement un résumé de la
situation qui reste pour le nouveau juge
donc considérer pages qui a un truc
vraiment énorme nouveaux qui arrivent
c'est de la manier pour moi c'est de
c'est de la manipulation la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il faut pas non plus
perdre de vue l'idée pour je suis mieux
placé pour là pour le dire parce que je
les ai vécus l'idée que le rn a quand
même le plus grand mal à obtenir des
financements c'est pas un parti comme un
autre
j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit que lorsque le
mode manoir exemple fait ça ou lorsque
la france a soumis ce fait ça est bien
ici outre à ces gens qu'ils ont pas
vraiment de raison de le faire bosser
des vosges et érigé des candidats dont
j'étais candidat j'ai été candidat aux
élections législatives je devais ouvrir
un compte de campagne
eh bien figurez vous qu après avoir
écumé toutes les banques pour ouvrir mon
compte de campagne
aucune banque n'a brillé que les cas le
salut que la plante de l'hérault
oblige une autre une banque française à
m'ouvrir un compte de campagne ça a été
le cas pour paix sociale alors